when I say thank you very much everyone
we've come here today I'm delighted to
say the Labour Party National Executive
has decided that on the ballot paper we
will be campaigning on all the things
that matter the inequality and poverty
that exists in this country the need to
end the privatization of our National
Health Service the need to give real
hope and opportunity to young people all
across this country
that's what Labour exists the
campaigning work we're going to be doing
the length and breadth of this country
and that will strengthen our party in
order to defeat this Tory government and
bring in a government that cares for the
people is a new kind of politics where
one person speaks to each other police
decide who's gonna go first
what about what about what about your
competence as leader that's what many of
your MPs have concerns about it's your
competence I'm reaching out to everyone
in our party I'm reaching out so that
all the talents in our party can be used
that is my message and I say to anyone
who has any disagreements
talk about a legal challenge Laura
koontzville you've just said if people
have a problem they should come and talk
to you about it the point is they have
come and talk to me about it repeatedly
over recent months how do you ever hurt
to persuade the vast majority of your
MPs you just don't figure up to the job
I've had to fight so hard just to be a
candidate how can you get them on board
I'm sure Labour MPs will understand that
the party has to come together has to
come to has to come together in order to
present to British people the options of
a different and better way of doing
things I have been inactive last year
with ten months ago today with a very
large mandate I respect that man take
its responsibility I'm carrying out John
John Drake are you worried about a legal
challenge being mounted by your
opponents against what's happened today
I would hope there isn't going to be a
legal challenge there's been a very long
legal discussion as afternoon there were
very well-qualified lawyers on hand to
advise so I think we're fine thank you
that's being decided at the moment okay
thank you very much thank you